so you know team of Leslie and Mike and
Betsy's you know just extraordinary it's
I'm honored to be here for them but even
more so for you and I'm humbled you know
it's very may be the most difficult talk
I have all year because I I wonder what
I could possibly say to you because you
guys are coming here for so far in your
circumstances are challenging and
different and you loo have different
things you're thinking about although we
may have a common goal of improving the
human condition in promoting health and
trying to help people in thinking of
what our unique contribution can be that
way the worlds are so distinct and so
it's with humility that I come to you
and want to share some ideas with you
but recognize that we're in a different
place and that you know a world that's
very different from my world your
experience is very different from my
experience and I would never pretend to
tell you what you need to do but maybe
through common shared understanding we
can learn from each other and have ideas
about how we can do our work better in
each place where we work and for one
thing I mean for you to come to the
North American continent when you've got
the world cup well that shows great
dedication to your work it's a I'm
extraordinarily impressed by that and so
I just want to start by making sure I
see the group so loose from Ethiopia ah
great group and looking from Ghana yeah
that's great and Liberia Wow yeah and
Rwanda yeah you know I that really gets
me you know that you guys are coming and
you what starts strong and big groups I
think it's really a wonderful and
amazing and I wanted to tell you one
other thing which was I I'm so we're
supposed to be speaking about
measurement today and you may know that
you fill out evaluation forms you know
we actually measure ourselves but you
measure us you know in and i gave a talk
last year they were too kind to me i
mean my talk was okay it was okay
and you say how do you know it was okay
well because i looked at the grades that
i was given and it was good but it was
actually very good but he wasn't as good
as Betsy streets and so maybe she wasn't
going to invite me back because of my
grades I don't know but but I begged her
i said i want one more chance to do
better so but i've paid attention to the
to the measurement I mean it meant
something to me I understand that
different people are giving different
topics on different days and of course I
know that Wednesday morning is probably
going to get the lowest score because
it's in the middle it's it's it's in
it's in the middle of the week it's
probably the most difficult spot in the
entire schedule so I understand that you
know I've been given this spot on
purpose and that's one of the challenges
of measurement is being fair when the
person is giving it on Wednesday
happening so when you're reflecting on
the range of talks that you've heard you
not only think that I enjoy the top but
where was it positioned exactly and was
it really did that person have the full
opportunity to shine and do well so the
there's a lot of complexity and
measurement and subjectivity and by the
way you're very handsome man i want to
tell you
so you know how you feel about the
speaker may reflect all of you are
actually it's a dress so well today's
its it may reflect on your
interpretation because we measure things
sometimes with high subjectivity and
sometimes we try to be objective but the
truth is there is no pure there is no
pure objectivity and so we have to take
these things into account when we are
thinking about measurement and so I beg
Betsy to give me one more one more
chance to at least tie her this year so
but I don't want you to think of any of
this when you're filling out the
evaluation I want you to forget
completely my plea to you and I know
this is the lowest of low it's a bit to
resort to this video with that thank you
very much because I heard short is also
favored that if you if you don't keep
people and talk too long they they like
that so that's part of gaming you know
you realize that there's ways to make
yourself look better and so forth well
another piece to get into about
measurement I what I wanted to do is
just share with you some ideas and we've
been working in quality improvement for
a long time I would never say i've been
working in measurement for a long time
measurement is a tool it's part of your
your box of things that you're using
your tools to help you achieve a final
goal and it's not in and of itself the
thing that you care about what you care
about is improving the human condition
about helping others and figuring out
how best to do that but it's closely
related to this idea about quality and
quality improvement and I just want to
tell you a little bit about an insight i
have and at least reflect to you some of
the challenges that we've had in this
country when we start talking about
quality and process and organization
because it's so tightly can
acted with measurement you can't embark
just on measurement unless people feel
that they understand where it fits and
they they are convinced that we need to
be able to track what we're doing in
order to get somewhere that it begins
it's part of our toolbox part of what
we're using to get somewhere and in this
country at least I'm trained as a
physician I am a physician I'm clinical
physician I was taught in the tradition
of physicians to think about one patient
at a time and to go deeply into that
patients need and to respond to their
problems and to try to fix what that
individual has I wasn't hard to think
about populations I wasn't taught to
think about systems I was taught about
what to do there wasn't a lot of
emphasis on how to do it exactly I mean
of course you're taught how to do
procedures and so forth but the way that
you may be set up to run a clinic or to
ensure that people are getting the right
medications or they're taking the
medications or you're diagnosing things
correctly i mean the how peace that
accountability piece wasn't part of my
education and when I began to realize
that there were opportunities to save
many more lives and the person in front
of you and it always remains a great
privilege to take care of the person in
front of you but when I began to realize
the power and potential to have an
impact far beyond what the person was in
front of you I realized how ill-equipped
how poorly positioned my colleagues were
to begin to think that way now I'm not
saying okay bye was smarter or more
advanced but I was exposed to certain
ideas early in my career that made me
think that there were ways to enhance
the performance to get more out of the
effort that's being made then we
currently are getting to yield as if
it's a field and you're harvesting you
know we can get more bushels out of that
field if we are smart about the way we
plant and fertilize and harvest then if
we basically just tell a bunch of people
what to do we send them out and we
assume everyone's doing fantastic we
start really beginning to count the
specials coming out of that field we can
recognize that that farmers doing better
than that farmer and that there are
different ways that can potentiate the
yield the success and we can do a lot
better begin thinking like this and as I
begin talking to my colleagues they
thought I was from another planet they
didn't quite get the connection because
people would say to me things like you
don't understand we are so busy we do
not have time for this people either are
dying or people are sick or we're
understaffed we have got too much going
on here at the end of the day I don't go
home till nine I mean I have no time in
my day you want me to meet about this
you want to have us to devote time not
towards actually caring for the people
the long line out the door but you want
us to care you want us to take time away
from our day I mean we don't even get
through everything we need to do by the
end of the day so there's a strong
mentality that there is no time for this
because we have people standing out the
door who have immediate needs that we
have to tend to and that was throughout
all areas of Medicine whether your
surgeon whether you're an internist with
your pediatrician I mean in this country
like your country people in health care
are working hard they're working hard I
mean I it's not a place where lazy
people go for vacation it's it's you are
they are breaking a sweat every day and
I'm amazed it no matter what country you
go to the dedication and the effort
that's put in by your average person of
course we all have no there's maybe a
few people somehow they're not devoting
themselves quite the same but in general
in general people working quite hard and
they're used to you know this shovel and
the next show I mean they are just each
task in front of them I mean they're
trying to move this this mound of dirt
to this side of the room I mean they're
just they don't have time I mean they're
in the task that they're doing at the
moment and I begin thinking about what's
the metaphor for this you know how can I
communicate well
about this issue because if you don't
buy into the idea that there are better
ways of doing things you can get more
bushels from the field that introduced
so we have to take a step back and
actually invest our time our effort our
dollars in improving our systems if you
can't buy into that then the measurement
is useless I mean what if no one's going
to pay attention to it no one's going to
act on it people are going to find ways
to undermine it they'll use it for
political purposes it won't be real the
real is it fits into a construct that
people understand that's fundamentally
part of a mission to improve care and
get more bushels out of each field to
say we can do that with the resources we
have we always want more resources but
we can make better use of the resources
we can get them to work for us better
and I'm just telling you in this country
I mean you may think well you've got a
lot of resources well we do but we waste
a lot more than anyone to and you don't
see us getting more bushels than people
spending less there are many countries
spending much less than we are that are
getting the same bushels out of the
field that we are and so you have to ask
the question is it weighs store is
inefficient or what is going on what can
we do how can we be smart and so the
metaphors I have been thinking about you
know these these these guys they go out
on a boat and you know actually there
are three boats so I'll tell you a story
of three boats the boat goes out on the
water and they're far from shore and all
of a sudden they recognize that the
boat's leaking and you've got five five
friends who are together on the boat and
so they're smart they know they brought
buckets with them and they see that
there's a leak and they start emptying
the boat now there's two problems one is
there's a reason the boats
filling with water and but they don't
have time to think about that they have
to empty the boat they're worried the
boats filling it didn't think about
second thing is there are holes in the
buckets they're not big hole it's not a
complete hole in the bottom so that
every time you pull out a water the
whole thing goes through it's a medium
sized hole so every time you pick up
with the water some of that water maybe
half of that water falls back into the
boat and the five of them have to work
so hard in so fast to keep the boat from
sinking and one of them says to the
other well maybe we should you know look
at the buckets or took at the leak and
the others all say we don't have time we
don't have time we've got to continue to
empty the boat and so the five friends
in that boat are in a what we would say
a predicament they're in a big
predicament what do they do they cannot
convince themselves that they have the
luxury of time or resources to do
anything else but what they're doing and
all they can do is stay even which is
falling just a little bit until they
sink they're not sunk but they're closed
and the water keeps coming in and they
keep emptying and they keep doing it
losing half the water and they can't
think beyond that that's the one boat
there's another boat different set of
five friends they go out they go far
from shore the boat starts leaking
they're smart too they've got buckets
they got the same buckets they bought it
from the same guy
it's got a hole they were cheap though
they were inexpensive they didn't have a
lot of money they start emptying the
boat now this is a bunch of quality
improvement people they're smart five of
them they say you know we got a problem
we got a boat feeling there's a hole
somewhere we have we have buckets they
have holes very smart they've been to
this course they say we're inefficient
we're not doing what we could be doing
we could be doing better they all agree
they said we have to have a meeting
about this they meet both fills with
water they assign four of them to
measure the one to see how well he's
doing the empting they carefully
calculate how much is being lost from
each bucket they're measuring carefully
how fast the boat the water and the boat
is rising the one wants to make sure the
other is measuring it right so one of
them is just assigned to the other
measure to be sure that the measure is
doing it correctly he's auditing the
measure wants to be sure and the boats
continues to sink until it sinks right
because then you've got a third boat the
third boat you can guess now right the
same different five guys I don't know
that it's this group of people they're
not thinking but they go out they've got
a boat it begins to leak they've got the
buckets they continue to work to empty
but they're talking they recognize how
much time have we got there balancing
the need to continue to empty the boat
with the recognition that they can be
more efficient they find ways to while
they're still emptying the boat to work
together to use some of their time to
fix the bucket and then use some of
their time to find the hole to at least
make the hole in the boat smaller if not
get rid of the hole
and but they do it in parallel right so
they don't ignore it and say we don't
have time for this because then all
they're doing is emptying the boat until
their arms fall off with with pain and
the boat will sink eventually it will in
the first case in the second case they
don't put too much resources toward the
measurement a ridiculous out of
proportion effort on measurement that
has no hope of true success because now
you've taken all this valuable thing in
the boat it keeps filling now because
you're now not attending to the threats
that's right outside your door and
you're not providing the service that
needs to be done but they're balancing
they're recognizing the way out of this
predicament is to continue to empty the
boat while at the same time spending
your attention to make sure you're doing
it better and recognizing what the
underlying cause may be so you're trying
to slow the water into the boat as well
at the same time the water that's
already in the boat is being more
effectively more efficiently taken out
of the boat so it's this kind of
metaphor it's this kind of thinking that
we need to i believe do to convince our
colleagues about what we're talking
about because if they feel that we're
talking about just measurement for
measurements sake it doesn't matter what
we do the measurement will not help us
if they feel that we're ignoring the
need because in the third case there
still is water coming in the boat I mean
you have to get that water out of the
boat we have people who are already sick
they have to be attended to we can't
take time out and let that continue to
rise without addressing it so this is
the balance these are the issues within
within it that are so I believe
important and we have in our country a
lot of efforts around measurement that
are nonsensical that all they do is add
burden they provide no return they
provide no
Comfort that the effort that's been
invested is going to ultimately improve
any single person's life and when people
look bad and they start to look good
everyone's convinced it's only us a
matter of making sure we write something
down you know it's not changing actually
anything that's that's unfortunate it
undermines all of our efforts equality
it reduces people's confidence that any
of these tools can be beneficial and
especially when it's imposed from above
with measures that are inadequate and
difficult it doesn't do any service for
anyone and that is a very common because
people often find comfort in numbers or
the idea of numbers or a false idea that
this is going to be beneficial but we
also have had experiences in this
country were focused well grounded
scientifically rigorous measurement has
provided a multiplicity many benefits
including it has garnered clinical
attention it has gotten health care
professionals to recognize that there's
an issue where they never saw one before
without the measurement there was an
issue that was invisible now comes into
view it has gotten political support
such that we were able to get resources
and direction and to begin to galvanize
investment to try to improve while we're
still emptying the boat while we're
still emptying the boat but but that
we're getting people to make that kind
of investment it brings about strategic
attention where people can begin to
realize it in a systematic way we have a
problem that needs to be solved it need
to develop a clear plan that is both
feasible and likely to be effective and
it provides a means of accountability
for what it is we're trying to
accomplish and I know you're getting
pressure from that and many for many
sectors about accountability
accountability but I do believe that in
the end of the day we're going to need
to say what results have we achieved and
it's not going to be enough to say
trust me this was a good program trust
me we it made sense it was sensible it
was of course we must have had a good
benefit because look at what we've done
we've have all these people out doing
all this activity and people more and
more are going to be asking about i call
it results-based accountability it's
like accountability on results on what
exactly happened and more and more
shifting not only toward for example in
the u.s. not just what you've done to a
blood pressure or cholesterol measure
mean we're dealing a lot with chronic
disease but how many lives are saved how
many lives are improved what can we say
about that what is the population
actually experienced and other tangible
benefits that we can point to that tell
us that this program has mattered now
that's not so simple many many of our
initiatives have a lot to do with a wide
variety of issues including some case of
social justice distribute distribution
of resources providing access allowing
people to get jobs and food as well as
health care I mean it's a it's a complex
web of trying to improve the human
condition and we can often are
handicapped to try to understand how one
aspect in health is moving people's
condition but still there we need to
continue to hold ourselves to say it
what evidence do we have that people's
lives have been enhanced that we are
doing better then we're getting more
bushels from that field that people are
getting the benefits so this is the way
we're think about in in the example that
we've done most recently here in some of
the work that we've done with the
government is we were able to steer the
government to think about a problem that
we have which is that people who leave
the hospital off and coming back quickly
to need to be readmitted when I was in
medical school no one talked about this
problem when I was in fellows and no one
mentioned it when I was actually taught
that
so we have a little like you know we're
so happy when someone leaves the
hospital two reasons they're leaving the
hospital that's good for them they're
leaving the hospital that's good for me
you know that they are off mice off my
responsibility that was a big mistake by
the way that culture that we were taught
to like okay great bye bye good luck you
know and I'm sure you don't have that in
Africa but in here we it was very much
there's the door thank you you know and
I hope everything turns out well it's a
is a mentality that led to us having one
in four patients coming back to need to
be admitted to the hospital within one
month within one month I don't know if
you know this about our country but in
heart failure for example one in for
many conditions one in five that's
amazing that's amazing I mean we would
never even say that to a patient you're
going home by the way I'm going to see
you again I'm sure you know it's a it
was happening but because we weren't
systematically evaluating this
particular issue I don't think any
doctor in America would have told you
that number they might have said maybe
ten percent maybe they would have said
five percent nobody because I don't know
why we sort of filtering it out you know
and also we are teens and sometimes if
someone comes back in I mean you might
walk down the hall oh hey how nice to
see you again I didn't know you were
here you know someone else is taking
care of them which is another problem
with our system the lack of continuity
or communication but but by beginning to
measure it we began to recognize that we
have a problem a problem in the
transition from people being in the
hospital to being out of the hospital in
the communication of information about
what happened in the hospital in making
sure they get an appointment outside the
hospital in ensuring they could afford
the medications that were prescribing
for them out of the hospital in making
sure we're not getting them out too soon
as we're trying to clear beds for the
next person because it think about this
it's like being in the boat then right
I'm pushing you out because I need
the bed but then you come back in a
month which is filling making my beds to
fold I'm by pushing people out too soon
i'm creating part of the crisis because
they're adding to the demand for beds
when they come back instead of maybe
keeping them one more day and avoiding
me having them need to come back for
four more days so it the best i might
just be even by doing that and so this
led us to start studying it to start
talking about it and then we were able
to get the government to say you know
we're going to measure it for all
hospitals and we were fortunate our
group was able to develop this measure
that is now publicly reported on the web
every hospital in America for three
conditions has their readmission rate
what percent of their patients for those
for heart failure heart attacks and
pneumonia are needing to come back to
the hospital within 30 days and then
when we were going to have a change in
the health care law we were able to get
some incentives actually put into the
law now I'm actually we could spend a
long time talking about in the end it
wasn't what I wanted but it's okay
because it's probably going to be
modified over time but it gets people to
put attention to this problem because
other than that the hospital's had no
reason they actually made money both
times they made money on the first
admission they make money on the second
admission there was no reason for them
in fact if they reduce readmissions they
reduce revenue I know this sounds awful
it doesn't mean they were promoting
readmissions
but they certainly weren't interested in
spending a lot of money to reduce them
either the government by saying we're
going to start paying attention and
payments are going to be related to your
readmission rate now you've got
attention now you've got the ability for
people to say we're going to invest in
this now now we have to support those
investments we have to understand what
makes the difference how can we do that
and same for mortality we have the same
three measures for mortality too and we
see a lot of variation we see different
hospitals being able to get different
bushels out of the field different
hospitals achieving different levels of
performance some hospitals having low
mortality rates some hospitals having
high mortality rates in my view my view
we can begin to understand the hospital
as risk factor some enhancing outcome
some diminishing if you look at the ends
of the spectrum going to a hospital with
a higher mortality rate is like going
with another risk factor like in a heart
attack having heart failure or not
having heart failure compared to a lower
hospital that you get what i mean by
that i mean it's like we've been
thinking okay you come in with a heart
attack and what's your heart rate and
what's your blood pressure do you have
heart failure we think about these
things is contributing to your risk
profile and i'm suggesting that there's
one more thing which hospital did you go
to because that can increase your risk
thirty percent or decrease the thirty
percent in this country and this is the
challenge we have now getting people to
think wow admit it to my hospital does
that enhance the chance that they're
going to survive or be able to go home
and not have to come back or does it
increase the risk the environment as a
risk factor the organizational structure
of the hospital as risk factor or or as
beneficial intervention treatment right
that's something we can do about it the
idea that we can measure in targeted
ways with scientifically rigorous
metrics that we can trust puts us in a
position to do quite a lot of good poor
measurement poorly distributed not well
thought out inappropriate
tribution of resources on the
measurement given what the needs are can
put us behind and so in the end it's
going to be up to us to chart this
course measurement is neither good nor
bad in its own right it's a tool that
can be used to great utility in the
proper context if people understand and
buy into the idea that the performance
of the system matters and that we can
use the measure to our purpose for
enhancing performance organizing
interventions holding ourselves
accountable for what we achieve and
building on it for the next thing and
you it really is it means by which we
can we can move forward we can move
forward so I am I know we were going to
end it at nine-thirty I wanted to have
some time for discussion but what the
most important thing I wanted to convey
was how it fits you know we can we can
teach a lot about the details about
measurement it's hard to do it in a half
hour or 20 minutes but the conceptual
piece as I think of the starting point
because we can give you the skills and
provide you the help and support and we
can learn from you about how you're
doing things but but we have to be in
common understanding of ideas and what
I've shared with you I believe I mean
I'm telling you what my experiences here
but I believe it may be relevant to what
you're encountering too because there's
certain universal peace to this I think
that that matters across all systems and
in in within the culture of health
medicine and health but I don't know if
you want to take questions we should
just end because we have a break but i
want to thank you very much for your
attention